sonriendo la cámara los buceadores
indonesios celebran su logro después de
varios días de búsqueda las autoridades
anunciaron que habían encontrado la caja
negra del avión de la aerolínea es wifi
y agua que se estrelló en el mar de java
[Música]
esperamos que las personas sigan rezando
nos llevará de 2 a 5 días a analizar las
grabaciones ojalá la grabadora de datos
del vuelo esté en buenas condiciones y
lleguemos al fondo de lo que sucedió
los buceadores también encontraron otra
grabadora aumentando las esperanzas de
que el audio de la cabina pueda ser
recuperado pronto el avión despegó del
principal aeropuerto de yakarta el
sábado y se sumergió en el mar dejaba
poco después acabando con la vida de las
62 personas a bordo las autoridades
también han empezado a recuperar los
restos humanos
cuando escuché que el vuelo 182 se había
estrellado pensé que no había manera de
que mi hermano hubiese muerto
las autoridades dicen que el avión
llevaba detenido bastantes meses debido
a la pandemia pero que había pasado una
inspección el pasado mes de diciembre
este es el segundo mayor accidente aéreo
en indonesia desde 2018 cuando 189
personas murieron a bordo del boeing 737
de lionel que también cayó en el océano